se confirmó la primera muerte por
omicron en el mundo fue precisamente en
reino unido en donde las autoridades
sanitarias ven con preocupación la
rápida expansión de esta variante el
primer ministro boris johnson confirmó
la noticia en su visita a un centro de
vacunación en londres y hong kong
instruye por desgracias y omicron está
produciendo hospitalizaciones y
tristemente se ha confirmado que al
menos un paciente ha fallecido por o
micrones
johnson afirmó también que el 40 por
ciento de los casos en la capital
británica corresponden ya a la variante
omicron esta misma mañana el ministro de
salud del país advertía de la rapidez
con que se están disparando los
contagios en la isla
espn
ya se está en deuda defensa lo que ahora
sabemos sobre omicron es que en primer
lugar se está propagando a un ritmo
fenomenal algo que nunca habíamos visto
antes se están duplicando cada dos o
tres días las infecciones y eso
significa que nos enfrentaremos a un
maremoto de infecciones estamos de nuevo
en una carrera entre la vacuna y el
virus
este lunes apareció también un informe
científico relacionado a la universidad
de oxford cuyos resultados preliminares
confirman la mayor capacidad de contagio
del nuevo linaje según el estudio los
pacientes previamente infectados o con
doble dosis de la vacuna no
neutralizarían por completo la variante
es probable que esto conduzca a un
aumento de las infecciones lo que podría
generar una nueva ola de infección
aunque actualmente no hay evidencia de
un mayor potencial para causar una
enfermedad grave hospitalización o
muerte es el segundo estudio junto al
publicado por facer bayón tec que afirma
que una tercera dosis sería eficaz para
neutralizar esta nueva variante con ello
el reino unido- ofrece desde hoy una
dosis de refuerzo para todos los mayores
de 18 años